thanks guys we are here with two super
fans guys where do you come from
and what brings you here okay well we're
from Chicago and we came here to support
our champion Fabiano Khurana of course
for people that want to get this a big
head world worthy not gonna go to my
site build a head calm and you can get
anything maybe want any size you want
this is the three-foot size and I
thought you go bigger go home in this
opportunity right amazing any
predictions for the big match tomorrow
yes and I really believe Fabiano is
gonna win Bobby throws it tomorrow to
give Magnus a little false confidence
going into the big match in November so
I'm gonna say Magnus wins tomorrow
fabbi takes it when it counts so what
about the chances that you give Fabi for
the match
percentage-wise how much how would you
assess him I would I would go as high as
55 percent for Fabiano for Fabiano yeah
amazing my edge just because in
observing his games I think he's
building up the momentum that he needs
you know to win it but again he he's a
student so you got to watch out for what
he will come up with on the board and of
course Magnus is the world champion so
he's gonna have to work very very hard
to accomplish that but we look forward
to to seeing the outcome be 55/45 how
hard you work we were just watching the
coverage in there and they're saying
there's a chance that fabi's going in is
number one given how everyone's playing
right now there's a chance for that to
be happening so I'm gonna say 5149 Bobby
with the slight edge because I think
they're two fantastic player I'm just
excited for a chance to see him live
because we were thinking about London
but this is way easier for our Drive
versus an eight-hour flight we
appreciate the opportunity yeah great
great venue here and really fantastic I
I've been watching videos of this chess
club for a while Jonathan it's um
then feingold and really enjoy the
teaching material and this is great
being here now well it's amazing to have
you guys here thank you for visiting and
don't forget tune in tomorrow if you
want to watch the big game Magnus
Carlsen versus Fabian Okara wanna go
Fabi